I once opened the door to a lady in
McDonald's for an elderly lady you would
have thought that I won the Nobel Peace
Prize my mom lost her you are a
gentleman you are a golden-hearted boy
the way you treat people not just your
sister but this woman and by the way you
know I think a lot about positive
reinforcement um and and how people look
for it and are addicted to it which is
why people who get positive
reinforcement for their looks you know I
think become vulnerable at times and
there two areas of positive
reinforcement for me in the first 15 18
years of my life one my mother around my
kindness and the way I treated people
and two the world of business when I
sold lemonade when I shoveled snow when
I washed cars when I sold baseball cards
School wasn't it Sports wasn't it I look
at people who struggle because school is
their positive reinforcement engine and
then real life comes in and there's
nothing similar to it